the new new york city mayor eric adams
he was dancing his way into work and he
came in real hot said he wanted to make
new york city the capital cryptocurrency
well i got news for you and i got news
for all the people in new york new york
has always been abrasive towards the
crypto industry and we just saw yet
another attack against bitcoin coming
from the state of new york what am i
talking about well the new york state
assembly just passed a bill to ban
bitcoin mining you literally can't make
this stuff up you know who else has
banned bitcoin mining china and the ccp
now of course if we look at the bill
itself what exactly are they trying to
accomplish here they state that they are
simply trying to create a moratorium on
cryptocurrency mining operations they
use proof-of-work authentication methods
to validate blockchain transactions and
all of this is being done under the
guise of esg or climate change
initiatives but i got news for you
whether you run a data center or a
bitcoin mining facility there are no
emissions
from the actual computers it's not like
the bitcoin miners are out here
polluting the earth that's not how it
works ultimately it's all about the
power generation so whether that power
generation is being used to power a
microsoft data center a facebook data
center or a bitcoin mining facility why
are they attacking bitcoin mining rather
than simply going after the power
generation sources it's because they're
either stupid or they intentionally are
trying to attack bitcoin there's really
no other explanation so if we take a
look at john olson what he stated coming
from the blockchain association is that
the intention of the bill is to prevent
new mining operations that would draw
power from fossil fuel generation even
if it's partial
the impact though is really just
economic in the sense that good paying
jobs are going to be going to other
states and mining operations that would
face less regulatory scrutiny in terms
of environmental impact would be setting
up shop in another state now of course
if we take a look at what people on the
ground are saying dennis porter had a
great point he said that new york is
trying to ban bitcoin mining and assess
fees on bitcoin companies while texas
has its arms wide open to miners and is
pushing forward policy to bring in more
bitcoin business
gee i wonder which state will increase
its gdp and job growth this year
there's no other way around it new york
has become abrasive the bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies their dream of becoming
the capital of cryptocurrency is just a
joke at this point if you want to be the
capital of bitcoin and cryptocurrency
then you've got to actually embrace the
industry
going after bitcoin mining because of
proof of work just shows you have no
clue what you're talking about and my
guess is that there are some very big
dollars some lobbyists that are putting
tons and tons of effort and capital
behind trying to push this forward if we
go back to john olson what he stated was
that there's a certain interest in
turning back on plants that use fossil
fuel use natural gas the industry itself
is always working on new technology to
improve emissions to meet standards to
capture wasted energy that would
otherwise not be utilized so it's a bit
of a blow to an industry that is very
much looking to be here in new york and
so what we have to remember
is that all sorts of leadership has
consequences good leaders lead people to
show up and start building
bad leaders chase people away that's
exactly what the state of new york is
doing right now if we go ahead and we
take a look at one last good laugh this
is a perfect point nick garland stated
that new york didn't ban bitcoin mining
because it is bad for the environment
they did it to take away your freedom
they care about climate change then they
should ban atms and christmas lights
next of course they're not going to do
that because it has nothing to do with
climate change this has nothing to do
with esg this is a bunch of people who
are uninformed who are creating laws in
an extreme fashion to simply score
points in the political arena if you're
worried about fossil fuel power
generation then ban fossil fuel power
generation i don't even think you should
do that but if that's really what you
want to do then go ahead and actually
target the root cause going after
bitcoin mining is ridiculous and it just
shows that new york is not the capital
of cryptocurrency in fact seeing that
the mayor of new york eric adams
supports it means that eric adams is
abrasive to bitcoin he's attacking
bitcoin and if people continue to
support him if people continue to laud
him as some great cryptocurrency hero
they're gonna be left holding the bag
because just another politician that was
out searching trying to figure out how
they can say whatever people want to
hear in order to get elected hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time